so much of piketty's book is about this
idea of more more and more returns to
capital that that the return to capital
is going to grow faster than the growth
of the economy and we see charts like
this where we have the value of private
capital as a percentage of income and we
see this dynamic and we see this dynamic
played out in multiple charts where as
we go through the gilda's age we hit
kind of a a peak right over here at
least a local peak and then as we get
into the beginning of the 20th century
it drops down and then it starts to pick
back up until the present time and this
is the present time right over here this
data point and then everything we see
after that this is pikadee's projections
really based on this idea of returns to
capital b growing faster that r is
growing faster than g
but one thing to think about is why this
dynamic might be happening and then that
might inform what how we think about
what the projections might be so let's
think about why the value of private
capital could go down and why the value
of private capital could go up
so one reason so let's just say we have
some asset some capital asset right over
here and let's say its current value i
went down some to some market and i
bought it
and its current value
is
one hundred dollars so this let me just
write this this is today
today it has a hundred dollars and let's
say it gives an income an annual income
of ten dollars of ten dollars so for
this asset my return on asset right over
here is ten percent
i get ten dollars on a ten percent on a
hundred dollar investment
now there are several reasons why the
value of this could go up
one reason is that this asset starts
producing more income so this would be
in line with the idea of more of maybe
income because of more of capital
becoming more and more valuable it's
able to capture more and more income or
maybe it's utilized in a better way and
so
let's write this as the future
so in the future
you could have a situation where it's
generating an income
it's generating an income of let's say
twenty dollars
and let's say that the return is the
same so the expected return is the same
so people are still willing to say you
know i i'm willing to pay as much for
things so i still get a 10 return
so people are saying okay i'll pay as
much so i still get a 10 return so that
means that they're going to pay
in the market they'll pay 200 for it so
this is one reason why you could have an
increase in the value of something and
you could go the other way maybe the
value is 200 but because the income goes
in half and the return stays constant
the value goes in half so this is one
scenario this is one reason why the
price of an asset could go up but it's
not the only reason why the price of an
asset could go up another reason why a
price of an asset could go up is maybe
there's more and more capital and maybe
there's fewer and fewer projects to put
it to especially if the growth of the
economy isn't growing
so more
capital
chasing
fewer
fewer projects or fewer
of things for it to produce and in this
world what is going to happen
well this we'll just assume that this
continues to produce ten dollars of
income
so the income
continues to be ten dollars a year
but people let's say you know i were
able to buy this for a hundred dollars
but let's say the next person who has a
hundred dollars to of capital or you
know to invest in capital says well i
can't find something with ten dollars of
of income i can't get ten dollars so hey
i'm willing to take nine percent so i'm
going to bid this up i'm willing to buy
this from you from 101 dollars or 102
and maybe it goes all the way where they
can't get anything they can't get better
than a 10 return anything better than a
5 return on their incremental 100
and so they're willing to do a 5 return
for this asset so they would bid this
thing up the more and more capital you
have chasing or more and more money you
have chasing this this project i guess
you could say this this asset could just
bid the value of this up
so the value
could go to 200
is still producing the same income and
now
the return is five percent
and so the reason to to point this out
is
a a increasing value of capital doesn't
necessarily mean increasing returns in
fact normally in the market they move
inversely with each other when bonds
have higher returns then you have lower
than their prices are lower when their
prices are higher for bond prices that
means that they have a lower a lower
return
so when we look at something like this
when we look at something like this this
could be speaking to more and more
capital accumulation chasing fewer and
fewer potential
projects or whatever it might be
especially because you have slowing
economic growth but this would be a
story of capital accumulation but with r
slowing down with the actual potential
return slowing down and probably
starting to converge to g to the rate of
growth another similar idea this is more
capital chasing fewer projects but you
also have might have a reality is that
the reason why this is getting a 10
return is people find it scary they've
been burned on investments before there
have been wars they don't want to put
their money into some kind of factory
they want to stuff it into their into
their mattress
but then over time maybe people become a
little bit less risk-averse and they're
willing to invest in the market they're
willing to
invest in a project or start a business
or whatever it might be and so people
become more risk tolerant so maybe this
is a world that is very risk-averse
risk-averse so if you want me to invest
in capital you have to give me a high
return but maybe the future is going to
be more risk tolerant
risk tolerant
risk tolerant and then in a more
risk-tolerant world you could also go to
something like this so this is risk
in a more risk-tolerant world you might
say hey okay well okay i don't have to
stuff in my mattress i'm getting zero
percent or in my bank account i'm not
getting a lot but hey and i'm willing to
take my money to invest it more in
capital and so once again they will bid
up capital and they will have a lower
expected return
here they needed a higher respected
return because there was a lot of risk
they were scared of things hey you
better give me a lot of return on my
capital if you want my capital because
it's a scary world out there hey okay
maybe now i'm less worried about wars
and my wealth disappearing and whatever
else so i'm more willing to invest and
so that also is in line with this more
capital and so there is a lower expected
return and so you have the value going
up and actually this is consistent with
what we see happening right over here
is that this
this period right over here was a period
this is a period of major unrest you
have the two largest wars in global
history right over here you can imagine
people becoming very very very
risk-averse you could imagine people
starting to stuff money and they're
putting putting their
trying to sell their assets worried what
might happen and so you're going to have
less and less capital more and more risk
aversion driving driving that reality
but then as we go into the post-war
period the memories of those wars go
away people become more risk tolerant
more capital comes into the system
because of the productivity you have
more and more capital accumulation if we
go back into
you know even pre-industrial revolution
times if we go to medieval times and all
the rest you had a limited amount of
capital it was mainly land as you go
into the industrial revolution
especially in the 20th 21st centuries
land represents a smaller and smaller
percentage of the value of total capital
now you have created capital you have
technology you have intellectual
property and so this could be a trend
once again i'm not sure it's up for you
to make the judgment
this trend isn't necessarily a return to
a gilded age it could be more and more
capital chasing fewer and fewer projects
which actually could be a sign of lower
returns or it could be just people's
risk premium is going down they're
becoming more and more risk tolerant and
so they're willing to accept lower and
lower returns so it's not clear what the
what the trajectory is but i just want
to make it very clear that this isn't
necessarily saying that hey because this
graph looks the same as here that we're
necessarily going into a second guilden
age but it's up for you to decide